I went to Community College here in New
York two years it was the two weeks two
weeks yeah there you go
are you a disappointment to your mother
at that point because she's so smart my
mother was a professor to University of
Penn like you said so I could have went
to the University to Penn for free but
she disappointed in you she gave me a
year she said go you got one year to
figure it out if you do not figure it
out you have to do it my way and she
helped you out financially this day she
supported me and she would give you
money but she'd hide it in the Bible to
make sure you were reading the Bible
right here a true story and I was late
on my rent and she kept asking me that I
read the Bible and I was getting pissed
off as a mom stop with the religion okay
this is a looks like I'm gonna get
evicted right I need you to give me the
money she like let me know when you read
your Bible we could talk about the money
she said it for the longest finally one
day this is a true story hand on the
Bible one day I'm in the room and I'm
like your mom is really tripping like yo
they're gonna evict me right but let me
just let me just open this Bible and
read the scripture I'm gonna pray I'm
gonna pray about this I open up the
Bible and literally like seven months of
rent checks
oh oh that's unbelievable sister and I'm
sitting there and it's like she's so
smart because she knew where to put it
and after that I said you know what I
got to do my mama's service and I
started reading the scripture every day
can you still do that no no no right
right okay great you could see Kevin
Hart and ride along to opening this
Friday January 15th and theaters
everywhere